[Music]
congrats to kelly osbourne she's going
to be a mom that's really exciting
to come
she delivered the pregnancy news on
instagram sharing a couple shots of her
holding a sonogram pick in the caption
she reveals she's over the moon to
announce she's going to be a mama i want
to be a mother yeah it happens when it
happens also writing quote to say that i
am happy does not quite cut it i am
ecstatic it's been a long time dream for
the star i thought it was the coolest
thing ever and now it's happening kelly
will welcome her baby with her partner
dj sid wilson of slipknot who also
shared his excitement over the
announcement with heart emojis alongside
this sonogram pick and while this will
be kelly's first foray into parenthood
she's gotten plenty of practice as
auntie to her brother jack's kids they
brought so much joy to our family
watching them grow up and learn and
seeing
like i see my brother when he was a baby
he's always my little brother even
though he looks older than me and
he's bigger than me
he's my baby brother i see the way they
interact and how much they love each
other and it's just like me and my
brother
and
we were inseparable and they're
inseparable
and it just it's so
incredible to see the next osborne
generation
making the story even sweeter kelly
thought kids might not happen for her at
all i would have loved to be married and
have children by now my brother has
three daughters and i would have loved
to have had a few kids by now but that
wasn't what was in the cards for me that
was kelly last year confessing on red
table talk how her struggles with
addiction put her dream on pause it's
something she hinted at to e.t back in
2015 too i
just don't believe in having children if
you don't if you're not mentally ready
for it i think that i would be a selfish
mother if i had a kid right now last
october kelly celebrated her 37th
birthday and being five months sober and
now she has even more reason to
celebrate reaching another milestone
first-time mom
[Music]